bien sûr judith comme vous venez d'en
tirer définitivement ce sujet devant le
passé au sujet suivant puisque c'est
vrai qu'il fallait faire un point
d'actualité mais pour expliquer que
finalement ça n'avançait pas on va donc
parler d'un autre sujet l'europe
toujours elle a signé la semaine
dernière la ratifier plus exactement
l'accord du mercosur qui est un accord
de libre échange entre l'europe et les
pays d'amérique du sud vous savez que ça
fait partie des prérogatives de l'union
européenne et de la commission en
particulier que de négocier ce genre de
traités internationaux
et bien cette décision n'a pas du tout
plu à nicolas hulot qui est l'ancien
ministre de la transition écologique des
manuels mâcon qui multiplient les
interventions publiques pour dire que le
libre-échange et est responsable de tous
les problèmes écologiques est
intéressant parce que souvent on dit
c'est la faute de la delà de la
consommation excessive ou bien de rouler
en diesel et mal annoncé le sait le
libre échange de sujet on va écouter à
nouveau
yannick jadot qui dit à peu près la même
chose et il en profite pour alpaguer en
quelque sorte le président brésilien
ball sonar haut et aussi le président
pardon le premier ministre du canada
trudeau parce que vous savez que
l'europe avait par ailleurs négocié un
accord qui s'appelle le ceta avec le
canada ball sonar au massacre
l amazonie trudeau au canada développe
les sables bitumineux qui sont les
pétroles les plus sales qu'on peut
extraire y participent au dérèglement
climatique et là je dis que franchement
le gouvernement le président de la
république sur ces affaires de libre
échange à une position d'une duplicité
indigne on est dans le mensonge
voilà et je vous propose d'écouter
maintenant un dernier point de vue un
petit peu plus mesuré peut-être c'est
celui de l'homme qui était le général en
chef du libre-échange puisqu'il était le
patron de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce c'est le français pascal lamy
est pour lui ben c'est un vrai sujet il
faut qu'on en parle
l'ouverture des échanges produit des
bénéfices dans certains cas et des
dégâts dans l'autre ça dépend de la
manière longtemps à réguler et ça n'est
pas l'ouverture des échanges qui est
responsable de la crise écologique c'est
le capitalisme de marché qui est un
système désormais globalisé
on peut intégrer des préoccupations
environnementales l'époque passion
sociale les préoccupations de santé
publique dans des accords et voilà et
dans un souci de pédagogie je propose de
terminer cette petite présentation avec
ce tableau qui est maintenant bien connu
qui est le classement des pays émetteurs
de co2 c'est parfois que le pays au
monde qui a le plus profité du
libre-échange puisqu'il s'est ouvert à
au commerce international qui est
évidemment la chine est aussi le plus
gros pollueurs du monde
du coup c'est l'évidence débat peut-être
que peut-être que nicolas hulot n'a pas
tort en fait je pense quand même que le
réchauffement climatique est dû à un
certain nombre de problèmes convergent
oui probablement le libre échange de
cette façon est aussi liée à la hausse
de la consommation enfin c'est un
système qui est globale la halle ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'en revanche
aujourd'hui par exemple personne ne paye
le réel coût du transport
si on se mettait à payer le réel coût du
transport il est probable qu'on aurait
peut-être moins de soucis de
délocalisation que ce qu'on achète ne
franchirais pas autant de kilomètres et
serait donc bien moins polluants et en
fait je crois que derrière la question
du réchauffement climatique et à la
question d'un changement de nos modes de
jeu mais qui paye alors le réel coût du
transport si c'est pas le le client
parce qu'a priori pas de marche mais qui
viennent de chine on paye aussi le
transport dans le prix final non et bien
pas tant que ça parce qu'en fait les par
exemple les carburants pour les avions
sont très très peu taxé alors que nous
nous faisons taxer énormément dé
comprendre notre petite voiture c'est
dans ce sens là et il ya en fait c'est
surtout le prix des carburants qui est
très aidée dans le cas de certains
transports et pas du tout dans le dans
le cas d'autres
donc je pense réellement que la vraie
réponse elle est dans un changement de
mode de vie
elle est dans les circuits courts elle
est dans d'autres manières
deux fils de vivre et de consommer et
que ça aujourd'hui personne ne dit de
façon extrêmement franches
parce que dire c'est la faute du marché
libre des échanges en fait c'est la
faute de quelque chose qui n'existe pas
qui n'est pas désignée qui peut pour
certains un certain nombre de personnes
est parfaitement abstrait mais ça permet
de ne pas faire peur quand vous dites
aux gens
étant donné la façon dont nous
consommons les ressources il va
peut-être falloir changer de mode de vie
là vous fait peur quand vous vous dites
il va peut-être falloir changer de façon
de produire là vous faites peur et
pourtant je pense que c'est sur ces
discussions là qu'il faudrait rentrer
plus tôt que sur la mise en accusation
moi j'en ai marre d'essayer de chercher
des coupables je préférerais qu'on me
propose un petit peu des solutions parce
que le réchauffement climatique
oui c'est un vrai problème et oui un
moment donné on a des enfants doit
penser à eux
mais faisons le de façon très concrète
arrêtons les mises en accusation et
voyons clairement ce qu'il faut changer
dans nos modes de vie dans nos façons de
produire pour espérer faire durer cette
planète plus longtemps je les aime trop
les internautes qui vous suivent sur les
écrans en connaissent votre sensibilité
libérale et donc seront à tenter d'être
à votre point de vue là la hiérarchie
que vous venez de montrer il faut faire
attention parce que il ya une course à
tous les pauvres de kuznets qui explique
quand un pays se développe elle est
d'une grande audace comme la courbe de
laffer au début elle elle pas comme le
cours de lafarge dit des bêtises
c'est une cour d'orgue en dos d'âne au
début la pollution dont très très vite
avec le niveau de vie et au fur et à
mesure que la comble à faire quand tu as
trop d'impôts laurent périllaud au fur
et à mesure que le niveau de vie
augmente la pollution se met à diminuer
parce que lutter contre la pollution est
une préoccupation de pays riches
donc en fait ça va peut-être que
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que les chinois
ont dit qu'ils se préoccupent maintenant
de là et qu'elle leur bilan et les
villes avec des millions d'habitants
veulent rien de weert de du jour au
lendemain donc quand il tente la chine
atteindra ce palier à partir duquel
l'aller contre la pression commence à
être une priorité nationale et à être
efficace ça va rebaisser donc ce lien
entre entre la lidho ordre libre
entreprise le niveau de vie la pollution
n'est n'est pas aussi clair que ça la
libre entreprise
elle a fait reculer la pauvreté dans le
monde elle a accru les richesses et la
richesse est un moyen de lutte contre la
pollution et de lutte efficace dans son
projet oued on est dans des pays de
grosse consommation
c'est dans des pays modèles sont en gros
émetteurs ont été là vous vous raisonnez
en chiffres globaux si on prend les
émissions par habitant c'est quand même
beaucoup plus cohérent en fait de le
faire la chine n'est pas du tout le pays
qui polluent le plus au monde
ce sont bien les états unis en fait le
plus gros pollueurs et les russes sont
juste derrière
donc ce sont des pays qui sont en
réalité extrêmement avec poêle à bois
voilà oui là on le plante en balance et
sur le fond du jugement du lot et puis
après ça on va écouter bien sûr chômage
comme vous avez pris la parole matthew
key est bien et ce qui est intéressant
aussi d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit pascal
lamy dont le discours en fête change
progressivement de tonalité mais enfin
je veux dire on ne peut que s'en réjouir
en réalité on peut presque de façon
consensuelle considéré quand même que
notre modèle économique
pendant ce qu'on appelait trente
glorieuses en tout cas en europe a
produit de la richesse et une richesse
partagée
donc ce développement économique affaire
a fait reculer la pauvreté y compris
chez nous dans nos pays et a permis même
de faire reculer les inégalités
depuis 30 ans les choses ne sont plus du
tout les mêmes alors depuis trente ans
la pauvreté au niveau mondial a continué
de reculer en particulier parce que
l'asie est sorti de la misère et comment
la très grande pauvreté les famine en
afrique
absolument tout ça recule comme
absolument pour autant pour autant
depuis trente ans on constate aussi que
le développement économique qui reste
rapide a profité à une minorité de gens
en occident dans les anciens pays
développés que dans ces pays là les
dynamiques inégalitaire ont repris et
surtout depuis trente ou quarante ans on
sait que notre modèle de développement
détruit la planète
il détruit la planète et ils désagrège
nos sociétés et donc ça tout le monde
commence à le dire pendant trente ans on
ne remettait pas en cause la mécanique
même de la mondialisation que tout le
monde ou à peu près qualifié d' heureuse
aujourd'hui plus personne ne se risque à
faire ce diagnostic est donc y compris
un pascal lamy est en capacité de
remettre en cause ce qu'a été la
philosophie dominante pendant très
longtemps et donc nicolas hulot dit
juste quelque chose d'évident
alors ensuite il ya un concours de
circonstances ou plutôt un calendrier un
peu baroque qui fait que quelques jours
seulement après un scrutin européen où
ce sont les verts en particulier qui ont
été les grands gagnants du scrutin
on signe effectivement un accord de
libre échange d'une ampleur relativement
inédite et dont personne ne conteste que
s'il peut éventuellement générer de la
croissance économique et des échanges
pour un certain nombre de pays cela se
fera malgré tout probablement au
détriment de la cause environnementale
d'où ce mot habituellement tabou dans un
monde ouvert aux échanges de
protectionnisme c'est ça la solution a
priori ce serait ça serait le
protectionnisme mais il faut expliquer
pourquoi
en tout cas j'ai fait vous couper pour
emmener dans votre sens le tableau vous
avez montré elle n'est pas correct si
les pas ramener la population la france
et 60 millions ce sens avec 68 millions
d'habitants ont fait 356 millions de
tonnes de co2 les chinois font font
quasiment 1000 mais ils sont 1 milliard
300 millions ces actions rapportent à la
si nous étions aussi nombreux que les
chinois j'ai fait un rapide calcul on
serait en serait à 70 ces différences
les américains effectivement sont encore
plus
pollueur sur le très amusant d'entendre
pascal lamy exprimer ce changement
d'orientation puisqu'il a été un des
principaux artisans
tout en venant du parti dit socialiste
un des principaux artisans du libre
échange dans le monde et qui n'est pas
tellement le libéralisme le libre
échange
les accords de libre-échange tous ceux
qui ont été signés que soit le ceta le
gft à hulu le mercosur celui avec le
mercosur parle très peu de liberté et
fort peu des changes
ce sont surtout des accords
internationaux qui garantissent à des
multinationales un monopole total et les
capacités politiques d'écraser les états
nations et les lois nationales
ce qui fait que dans les pays fragiles
oui justement concrètement faire revenir
et on est pratiquement oui mais les
réalités de base font qu' il ya par
exemple des tribunaux d'arbitrage qui
imposent leurs normes as des as des as
des pays où les lois ont été votées
démocratiquement par des gens élus par
le peuple de ce pays là ce n'est
maintenant grâce à ces à ces traités de
libre-échange peuvent s'imposer des
normes qui ne sont pas celles que
souhaite un pays hors imaginant prenons
par exemple la pâte la patron de la
fnsea qui est franchement pas une
organisation qui se taira qui se
caractérise alors du mac os
voilà qui est pas bolchévique un homme
là madame christiane lambert elle dit
c'est inacceptable
ni très écolo c'est une signature qui va
exploser exposer les agriculteurs à une
concurrence déloyale et les
consommateurs à être à une tromperie
total et bien oui là on ne peut pas
résister l'accord signé en interdit à la
france si elles le souhaitaient de dire
au brésil non nous ne voulons pas
acheter des boeufs qui sont produit
trois fois moins cher que des creepers
on verra comment elle sera mise en place
mais regardez le quiva ailier mais on
verra comment elle sera mise en place
en l'occurrence si la patronne de la fns
soit s'insurge c'est qu'a priori ils ont
vu que les clauses de sauvegarde comme
d'habitude dans ces traités là sont très
faibles pour les peuples et les pays qui
qui souhaiterait par exemple défendre
leur droit social ou l'écologie pour le
problème c'est que les prix
vont à la baisse dans l'économie
mondiale parce que c'est il ya qu'il n'y
a que deux moyens d'agir sur le prix
c'est le coût du travail et le coût
écologique si vous autorisez par les
accords de libre échange
encore une fois qu'il ne parle pas de
liberté et très peu des gens à des
multinationales de produire en payant
peu et en ne s'intéressant pas
l'écologie et bien vous aurez des
catastrophes écologiques majeurs je
rappelle quand même que selon le c2 qui
parraine pas une institution
spécialement embauchés lic 30% du co2
qui est déversée dans notre atmosphère
vient des échanges marchands en
particulier des transport par bateau
il est absurde que nous produisions des
porcs en bretagne et qu'il soit écart et
en allemagne parce que le travail est
moins cher ça fait deux déplacements
parfaitement inutile si nous avions
apporté possibilité de faire du
protectionnisme
nous dirions non n'entre sur le
territoire que des produits qui ont été
fait de manière correcte pour le travail
et pour l'écologie si ce n'est pas le
cas comme trump on tape du poing sur la
zone et 203e 400 amérique
c'était un très grand pays qui a marqué
l'histoire c'est qu'il est tout à fait
capable de mettre des barrières
douanières ça ne demande pas non plus
des des choses improbables et
exportatrices en ce moment et que le
commerce extérieur de la france est dans
un état assez lamentable ont tangué ne
pas gâcher un paysan tous les deux jours
un paysan tout un aviculteur tous les
deux jours sous l'égide jeudi live to
value barack obama mc la fermeture des
frontières sur la solution au problème
des balises et lisez le livre de
houellebecq
vous verrez que
même lui prend ce sujet à bras le corps
et ça ne va pas ça ne va pas que tuer ta
pas qu'est ce qu'on fait afin de
sélectionner les frontières ont faim
mais non japonaises mais regardez la
suisse pourquoi ils arrivent ils ont des
qu'ibra beaucoup plus petit que le nôtre
et bien il y arrive ils défendent leurs
agriculteurs ils défendent leur
industrie et il met 2 et des barrières
douanières
quand il impose par exemple que les
transports de se fasse en train et par
camion contrairement à nous avec un
président qui libéralise totalement le
transport routier qui favorise les bus
et tu le train
ces sont des politiques si vous donnez
la vie de nos internautes parce que ça
les passionne le modèle du libre échange
est il responsable de réchauffement
climatique et vous êtes une majorité qui
est en train de suivre à considérer que
oui à 61 %
voici quelques commentaires celui de
babineau qu'on ne présente plus nicolas
hulot dit qu'on ne peut pas avoir de
vraies ambitions de lutte contre le
réchauffement avec un tel système donc
système de libre échange donc ça
effectivement ça
explication de la position de l'ancien
ministre nicole nous dit le c'est avec
l'accord avec le canada et le mercosur
l'accord avec l'amérique du sud vont
détruire notre agriculture et sont
totalement contraire à l'écologie
prosper ajoutent-ils nous produisons
locale et que nous arrêtons le libre
échange
ça éviterait que des tonnes et des
tonnes de camions et de conteneurs
circule à travers la france et le monde
et puis un dernier mot qu'on va laisser
à edouard changer de mode de vie cela un
nom la décroissance ce mot est tabou
pour les responsables politiques et les
chefs d'entreprise
effectivement ça le risque céline pina
c'est que on se dit que si on régule
aussi on diminue le libre échange la
machine économique risque de s'étouffer
en fait pas forcément aujourd'hui elle
elle fonctionne pas forcément très bien
la machine économique
quand elle fonctionne on en arrive des
fois des résultats extrêmement
incohérent ça quand vous êtes sur des
territoires par exemple aujourd'hui on a
mis de telles normes que vous êtes
quasiment obligé pour nourrir les
enfants à la cantine à l'école et c'est
de passer par des systèmes industriels
on a cassé toutes les cuisines centrales
alors pour le coup ça fournissait du
travail ça
permettez de s'alimenter en circuit
court les peler la nourriture proposée
était bonne les enfants la manger en
plus je vous raconte pas tout ce qu'on
jette
l'espèce d'énormes gaspillages qu'on a
mis en place c'est un tout petit exemple
mais déjà on voit qu'on pourrait faire
des choses intéressantes après ont parlé
d'europe mais la france n'est pas censé
être tout seul si l'union européenne au
lieu de devenir un vaste concours de
notation de morale de ce que font les
pays
prenez vraiment ses responsabilités et
faisait ce qu'on a vu sur la filière
vélo la filière vélo on a réussi à faire
une filière qui est compétitive parce
qu'on a réussi à s'allier tous ensemble
et à protéger ce qu'on pouvait produire
aujourd'hui en france la douanière pour
contrer les vélos chinois mais oui et on
a su le faire donc on sait le faire
quand on veut il n'y a pas de raison
qu'on puisse pas le faire sur d'autres
produits